[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON POLITES: This
session is called
Life of a Serverless Event.
Really, the intent here is
to, just a little bit, lift
the cover on what
goes on underneath
in the serverless infrastructure
that we have in Cloud,
the building blocks
that we've built on
to provide the serverless
products that you can use.
So before we get started,
I just wanted to level
set on an assumption here.
And the assumption
is that we all
agree, in principle, that
serverless generally is
the place that we want to be.
You're not managing
infrastructure.
You're not dealing
with load spikes,
we'll deal with that for you.
You're not spending
time managing things
that don't add value
to your business.
You've elevated yourself to
a higher plane of existence.
However, there
are some problems.
Definitionally, we gave you
a black box and we said,
you don't have to worry
about all this magic.
We'll do it for you.
But that leads to
some issues in terms
of visibility and transparency.
You might see some
latency increase.
And how do you reason
about what that might be?
Maybe your build time
suddenly got longer.
Why is that?
And then you might
see different behavior
in one environment
versus another.
Or you're hitting some
weird quota limit.
And how do you reason about it?
So the theory is great.
You don't have to
worry about anything.
The reality is, you still have
to worry about these things.
So the purpose of
this session is
to just give you
insight into what's
going on underneath there so
that you can reason about these
with more intelligence.
And obviously, you would
have logging and monitoring
and all sorts of
things in place.
But as engineers, I think
it's useful to know,
what are the mechanics
going on under here?
So we'll cover
these four topics.
First of all, what's
the definition
of serverless compute
on Cloud Platform?
Secondly, what happens
when you deploy?
What steps do we actually take?
When you write that command
line, G Cloud functions deploy.
What happens when we receive
an event or a request?
How does that travel through
the system, and what happens?
And then we'll close
with some best practices.
What do you do with
this information
once we've revealed it to you?
Serverless compute
on Cloud Platform
covers two products, mainly,
Cloud Functions and App Engine.
I'll be referring to
these throughout the talk
as an app and a function.
You deploy an app
with App Engine,
you deploy a function
with Cloud Functions.
And there's just a distinction
that I've made there.
An app is something
that reacts to requests.
A function is something
that reacts to events.
You know, there's many
distinctions you can make.
That's just illustrative.
OK, how do we build a
serverless compute platform?
Now, if you wanted to go and
build your own serverless
compute platform, I'm going
to tell you how to do it now.
So take notes.
And if you want to go out
and start building your own,
then this is how you do it.
Step one, you need a global
footprint of data centers.
It's pretty simple.
There are actually servers
underneath serverless.
As you would know, Google
has a global distribution
of machines and data centers,
so it all starts there.
The next layer that
we have is something
that we've talk publicly about.
It's this thing called Borg.
And what it is is a shared
compute infrastructure
that runs pretty much
every service in Google.
Everything from Google
Maps to YouTube to search,
and also Cloud.
And its premise is that
Google engineers, in fact,
operate serverlessly
and have done
for a very, very long time.
They don't reason about
physical infrastructure.
They just create tasks in Borg,
and those tasks go and execute.
The caveat is that it
only runs trusted code.
It runs code that
is cryptographically
verifiable as Google code.
And your code, I hate
to say it, is untrusted.
So how do we run untrusted code?
Earlier in the year
at Cube-Con, we
talked about the open-sourcing
of a project we call gVisor.
And gVisor is a
unique technology
that we've created that is
a sandboxing technology.
It allows us to
isolate processes
on a shared compute
infrastructure from a security
standpoint.
So Process A has no
mechanism by which
it can interfere with
Process B. This allows
us to run untrusted
code on an otherwise
trusted infrastructure.
So above the data center,
above Borg, above these secured
processes we have a serving,
routing, and scheduling layer.
The serving is the data
plane that receives requests.
It's responsible for routing.
It does things like, if
a zone in a data center
is unavailable, it
will automatically
move an application
to a zone that
is available for that sort
of failover guarantee.
And the scheduling
part of it is the thing
that decides whether a new
instance of your application
needs to be created, whether
there's an old instance that
can be evicted, and makes
those decisions to auto scale
you up and down.
And above all of that
is the Google front end.
The Google front
ends sit at the edge.
They sit in front of every
single Google service.
Once the request hits
the Google front end,
from that moment onwards,
it's on the Google network.
It's on the Google operated
network from the Google front
end.
And it has some other
characteristics.
Like it does SSL termination.
It does some amount of
denial of service protection.
And that's the main
entry point at the edge.
OK, so all of these
layers, does it all work?
If we send this many requests
per year, 127 trillion,
that's a meaningless number.
But really, it's
about four million QPS
on this serverless
infrastructure
across both Cloud
Functions and App Engine.
That's a pretty big number.
OK, let's get to the good stuff.
I'm going to talk
about the life cycle.
What happens when you deploy?
When you execute
that CLI command,
what's actually happening?
And then once your application
is serving traffic, how do we
route the request to you?
And what's going on?
How are we scaling up and down?
And what are some
of the side effects
of the implementation we have?
OK, first of all, deployment.
You enter this command into
your CLI, or you use the UI.
And the first thing
that happens is build.
Concretely, in the case of App
Engine and Cloud Functions,
we're going to build
a container image.
And the latency there is going
to be a function primarily
of the file size and
your network speed
to get the data up to us.
Then we can actually crunch
that together into an image.
And most of the time spent
there is resolving dependencies.
Particularly in
Cloud Functions, we
have this ability to resolve
the dependencies for you.
If there's any Node.js
developers in the audience,
you'll recognize this
as a package.json file
that you will upload along
with your source code that
declares a set of dependencies
in Python, requirements.txt.
We'll go and resolve those for
you and bake it into an image
so you don't need to upload all
of your dependencies in one go.
Once it's built, we create
or update that instance
on the infrastructure.
And the latency there is
a function of two things.
One is cold starts,
which I'm going
to talk a lot about today.
And the other is
a rolling deploy,
which doesn't seem like a
latency impacting thing.
But the idea here
is that you already
have a version of your
application running.
You want to make a change to it.
That version is already
serving traffic.
You don't want to
kill that traffic.
You want to gradually
roll that out.
So the time between when
you made the change, when
you updated the function,
and it becoming available
across the fleet is not instant.
It's never atomic.
And so, there's
an amount of time
that that's going to take
that could be perceived
as sort of deploy time.
Just reiterating.
At the point we build this
dependency resolution,
we have some caching
mechanisms there.
If you depend on a particular
version of a particular module
or library, and we
can reliably identify
that we've seen that before,
we'll pull it from cache.
And then the rolling deploy.
Again, it's not atomic.
It happens over
the course of time,
depending on how much
traffic you have.
If you have a lot of
traffic and there's
a lot of instances
of the old version,
then it will take longer for
the roll out to complete.
If dependencies change, a
side effect of the caching,
obviously if
dependencies change,
then the build time
might take longer
because they're not cached.
OK, what happens when we serve?
So we have, from the diagram
before, serving and scheduling.
These red boxes represent the
instances of your application.
A request comes in.
If we don't have
an instance that
is available to serve a request,
then we'll create a new one.
We'll scale up.
This implies a cold start.
I might be preaching
to the converted
here in the sense of
what a cold start is,
but it warrants some detail.
OK, I'm going to
take a quick detour.
I put this slide in to
remind me that it's a detour.
And I want to talk about
three things really quickly.
This is a little
bit complicated,
but I'll do my best.
Concurrency and billing.
Products like Cloud Functions,
one of the advantages of this
is you're not paying
when you're not using it.
And even more fine
grained than that,
you're only paying while
your code is executing.
Now, you can imagine that,
let's say I have a function
and I've said, I would like
512 megabytes of RAM, please.
And my function
executes for 10 seconds,
and so I'm paying for 10 seconds
of wall clock time multiplied
by the amount of memory
and the amount of CPU
that I've been granted
for that period of time.
If I was to put another request
at the same time in there,
the billing gets a
little bit complicated.
Am I being charged for both
requests of that 512 megabyte?
Am I sharing it somehow?
What if they're not at the
same time, one starts now,
one starts halfway through?
It starts to get very,
very complicated.
The simplicity of
the billing model
means that we are constrained to
a single request per instance.
So a function is built
per request independent
of the instance.
It's not your problem whether
there's 1,000 instances or one
instance to serve that request.
We might be doing a really
poor job of scheduling
and have 1,000 instances
sitting around costing us money,
but it's not costing
you anything.
An app, conversely, you pay for
the life cycle of the instance
independent of the request.
This is a fundamental
difference in the model.
And the reason I
have the slide here
is just to make this clear.
An app will deal with
many concurrent requests
because it doesn't affect
the billing at all.
The only thing that
affects the billing
is the life cycle
of that instance.
And that instance will
stay alive as long
as it's serving requests.
So this has an implication
to things like cold start.
In this chart
along the bottom, I
have the frequency
of cold starts.
How often do they occur?
And on the y-axis upwards,
I have the duration.
How long does each
cold start take?
These two happy faces are
places that we would be OK with.
One where a cold
start happens a lot,
but it doesn't take very long.
And the other where it might
take a long time to start,
but it doesn't happen
very frequently.
A virtual machine is very
much on the top left,
and we hope Cloud Function is
very much on the bottom right.
It is necessarily,
definitionally,
going to have more
cold starts because it
deals with a single concurrent
request and with scaling
up and down.
We don't want a lot
of machines sitting
around costing us money.
That means we have
to charge you more.
So we're going to try to
be reactive, very quickly,
to these spikes and
troughs in traffic.
But it means that you want
the cold start time to be low.
Typically, this
manifests in a difference
between the primitive.
An app will typically cold
start less frequently.
And you can imagine
this scenario.
An app, let's say, takes
10 concurrent requests
before its resources
are exhausted
and we need another
instance of it.
If you only have 10
requests, 10 QPS, let's say,
you only need one instance.
So that is starting
very infrequently.
You definitely don't
want to be this person,
very frequent cold starts
that take a long time.
That's the worst place to be.
This would be the awesome place
to be, but it's a bit mythical.
Very, very infrequent
cold starts
that don't take very
much time at all.
I mean, it does happen.
You might have a
function that has
a very quick cold
start that's cold
once a day and that's great.
But if you're building
a large application,
the likelihood of this
happening is pretty low.
But as long as you're in
one of those green spots,
you're probably OK.
OK, so this makes
the distinction,
the choice you're making,
between the primitive pretty
important.
If you're building something
that is multi-purpose,
so it has many endpoints--
like imagine a RESTful API
that has many end points.
Maybe there's some shared state.
Maybe you have a connection
pool, or some bit
of memory that you're
sharing between requests,
and you want to deal with many
concurrent requests at once
because of this shared state.
Then you would err on
the side of an app.
If, however, your compute
unit is single purpose,
it really just has one job,
there's no shared state,
all the state is stored
outside and you're
OK with a single
request at a time--
by the way, single request at
a time is often much simpler.
You have to do with far
fewer race conditions
when you only have a
single request in scope
at any on moment.
Then a function is where you
would tend to find yourself.
OK, there's the
end of my detour.
Again, on this idea of
app versus function,
in the app case-- and this
chart represents CPU time.
So m cycles or clock cycles.
And then along the
x-axis, the wall time,
the time back in the real world.
Imagine you have two
requests sequentially.
One request starts and
finishes, second request starts
and finishes, and some
amount of time in between.
The blue line here represents
CPU usage, effectively.
So in an app, let's
say the first request
uses a little bit of CPU, the
second request uses a lot.
And there's this
time in the middle
where the CPU is being used.
This is important
because, as I said before,
the billing model says
I'm paying for the life
cycle of an instance.
So I should be
able to do anything
I like during that life cycle.
And this is true in
the case of CPU usage.
If I'm only paying while
my request is in scope, as
in the function
case, then there's
not going to be any CPU activity
in between those requests
because there's no billing
model that accommodates for it.
So request number one, the
billing starts on the left.
And then when that request
ends, we stop charging you.
If we allowed your
CPU usage in that gap,
free bitcoins for everyone.
So this will become
important further on.
So an app model bills for
the lifecycle of an instance.
It handles concurrent
requests, and accommodates
for compute time outside
of the scope of request.
A function bills for the
lifetime of a request,
handles a single
concurrent request,
and assumes this sort
of freeze/thaw model
in between requests
where no CPU activity is
going to be allowed to happen.
OK, eviction.
So we talked about,
request comes in,
we don't have an
instance available,
so we're going to create
an instance for you.
And then you have a
trough in your traffic,
and we have 1,000
instances lying around.
What policy do we use to evict
these instances, to remove them
from our infrastructure?
OK, that's just showing
what an eviction is.
So generally, instance
eviction is lazy.
Meaning that we will tend
towards evicting instances when
we need the infrastructure
that they are consuming,
but not before.
The reason for that is that
the machines on the data center
floor largely have a fixed
cost whether your process is
running there or not.
There's an
opportunity cost to us
if you have a process
that's running
and we need that space
for somebody else,
and you're not using that space.
In which case,
we'll kick you out.
Generally, though,
what we try to optimize
for is not whether we are
creating or destroying
instances.
That's much, much more of
an implementation detail.
We just try to optimize
for performance.
We monitor things like latency.
We monitor things
like cold starts
because they're bad
for performance.
And we try to optimize
the scheduling algorithms
or try to alter the scheduling
algorithms to optimize
for those two things.
As a side effect
of the concurrency
that I described
before, apps will
tend to have cold
starts less frequently.
And that's because when each
subsequent request comes in,
it can be dealt with
on the same instance.
The number of instances we have
to create to serve the same QPS
is fewer.
And then the last
point is, sometimes
instances just go bad.
Maybe you hit an
out of memory error.
And even though
that request that
calls the out of memory
error is long gone,
the machine or the instance has
found itself in a bad state.
We'll detect that, and will
cease to send traffic to them.
Because we're ceasing
to send traffic to them,
they will become viable for
eviction at some later point.
OK, quick recap.
Serverless is awesome.
It's also not awesome when you
can't know what's going on.
Google knows how to serverless.
You all do, too, now.
So I expect to see many
serverless complete competitors
emerging after
this presentation.
And then we talked
about the life cycle.
What happens at deployment?
We talked about atomicity of
deployment, instance creation,
destruction, cold starts,
apps versus functions.
Background threads we didn't
talk about specifically,
but this was the compute
time in between the request.
OK, but what do I do with all
of this amazing information
that I've just been told?
There's some sort of
patterns and anti-patterns
that I want to talk about.
So let's look at some common
pitfalls that people fall into.
Number one, are we choosing
the right primitive?
Are we trying to jam
an entire Java Spring
application into a function?
And is that the
right thing to do?
What can we do to improve
our cold start time?
What are the best
practices there?
Oops, I'm sorry.
What do we do with
background threads?
I have this thread that's
running in the background.
A common pattern
in web applications
is receive the request,
respond quickly, and do
some work in the background.
Well, that's not going
to work in a function
because once you've
sent the response back,
that's a signal for
us that you're done.
And we're going to
throttle the CPU down,
and your background task
may or may not complete.
What do you do with
this auto scaling
where we scale up beautifully
and you denial of service
your own database because it
can't deal with the traffic
that we've been sending it
because we auto scale up?
And then I'll talk a little
bit about idempotency
towards the end.
Number one, choose
the right primitive.
Do you want to put your big Java
monolith into a Cloud Function?
Probably not.
You can.
You're going to have
horrendous cold start times,
and they're going to
happen very frequently,
and everyone has a bad time.
Do I put my big Java
monolith into App Engine?
Maybe.
Why wouldn't I?
Well, I wouldn't if I'm
relying a lot on state.
Serverless compute
products work best
when they assume that
they're stateless.
If you have to
persist state, you
will find circumstances
where the request where
you assume that state was there
finds that it's not there.
Now, it's a great
performance optimization
that you might be
caching things.
And if it's there, it works
faster, and if it's not,
you can go get it.
And that's fine, but
this is why I say maybe.
The best thing to
do is to make sure
that the application has
the appropriate granularity
of services.
Very, very tiny services,
Cloud functions.
Medium sized
services, App Engine.
Some anti-patterns with
relation to cold starts.
Again, if you assume a
stateful environment,
then this might be problematic.
What I mean by that is that in
a classic monolithic web app,
it's very common for the start
to load a bunch of state.
Maybe it's loading things
from a database into cache.
Maybe it's instantiating
objects ahead of time,
instantiating singletons,
whatever the case may be.
This design pattern
assumes, essentially,
the virtual machine
style of mode
of operating where
you start up the VM,
it does a bunch of work.
It might take five
minutes to start,
but that's OK
because you're only
doing it like once a month.
This doesn't translate
well to serverless
because your start/stop
cadence is much more frequent.
And then the last point there
is this primitive choice.
Choose the right primitive.
Now, we at Google need
to do the right job
in making that easy for you.
But really, choosing
the right primitives
set you off on the right
foot from the beginning.
OK, here's some code, in
case you didn't notice.
If there's any Node.js
developers in the audience,
don't come and
attack me afterwards
because what I'm going
to show you is pretty
much the antithesis of what
a Node.js developer will
tell you is best practice.
And they'd be
right, but I'm going
to show it to you
anyway because I
think it's a good illustration.
This would be pretty common
in a Node application.
And I'll just unpack
what's happening here.
I have some libraries,
some dependencies.
They are being required at the
top of my file, the first thing
that happens.
And then I have two functions
declared in the same JavaScript
file.
I have do something,
and do something else.
Each function uses only
one of those dependencies.
And I said this would be totally
sane pattern in an application
model or on a virtual machine.
The first function uses
the first dependency.
The second function uses
the second dependency.
Everyone's happy.
But the problem is, the
second function doesn't
use the first dependency.
So if I was deploying these
as separate Cloud Functions
even though they're in
the same source file,
the do something else
would be its own function.
But at cold start time, it would
be loading the first library
even though it
never, ever uses it.
Now, multiply this by 10.
How do you know that
all of the things
that you're doing at the
start-- and I'm doing
something pretty innocent here.
All I'm doing is following
Node best practice.
I'm just requiring a bunch--
I'm not loading a cache, and
I'm not doing anything silly.
I followed what they told me.
But the side effect of this
is that each function, when
deployed individually, is
bearing the cost of all
the other functions.
So this is unwanted
cold start time.
This doesn't offer me anything,
it just costs me money.
Here's a more insidious example.
The function is
using both libraries,
but only conditionally.
So if my query string foo
only equals bar in one
out of a million requests,
then all the other requests
are paying the price for that
in terms of cold start time.
This takes a little bit of
relearning in how we do things.
We have to be mindful of what's
going to happen at startup
when I deploy this thing.
We often hear, oh,
such-and-such product
or such-and-such platform has
good or bad code start times.
But largely, it's dependent
on this code that we write.
OK, this is where I'm going
to get in big trouble.
I'm not saying necessarily
do this, but this would help.
I only require the library
when it's actually required.
Now, a really great
feature of Node
is that that require
statement will be cached.
And so, the
subsequent invocation
of that on a hot instance,
it's effectively a no-op.
But this is, again,
just illustrative.
The ELSE condition that happens
in most cases, let's say,
doesn't pay the cost
of some huge lib that's
loaded in the IF condition.
Hope that makes sense.
OK, I want to invite my
colleague Monika on stage,
and she's going to
give you a demo.
Can we switch to demo, please?
MONIKA NAWROT: Thank you, Jason.
So my name is Monika Nawrot.
I'm a software engineer
in Cloud Functions team.
And for the purpose
of this talk,
I created a demo
that illustrates
what Jason has just said.
So it operates on cold start
and lifecycle of Cloud Function.
So in my demo, I
created three functions
that do more or
less the same thing,
but in a slightly different way.
So I integrated
functions with Slack.
So Slack is this
cloud-based tool
that aids team collaboration.
So I have my Slack channel.
And I also created a
free custom command that
are hard coded with functions.
So integration is very easy.
As you can see,
there is a command
and there's a URL
that should be called
whenever this command is called,
and it points to a function.
So let's try our first function.
So all of these functions do the
same thing, as I said before.
So they expect a term
in the Slack channel,
and they put this term
into Knowledge Graph API
and [INAUDIBLE]
information about this term
from Knowledge Graph.
And then it returns a response
which contains the data
from the Knowledge Graph.
So we can learn something
about this particular thing
from Knowledge Graph API.
So the first function is written
in application like style.
So as you can see, first
we extract the text.
So the term that was written
in the Slack channel.
Then we used a local cache.
So first, we tried to retrieve
information from the cache.
And if it's not there, then we
are making the actual query.
The query is on here, so we just
put the query to the Knowledge
Graph API, and we
extract the first result.
And then we do the formatting.
So we are converting the
message returned from the API
to the format that can be
displayed on the Slack channel.
So because it's application
like style function,
I also do some preloading.
So let's say that my Slack
channel is about traveling,
and people often look for
information on the countries.
So I want to make this
experience for them
really good, really fast.
So I'm preloading some data
associated with countries.
So in another file, I have
the list of all countries.
So now let me go
to my Slack channel
and try this, try to
call the first function.
And what actually
happened is that Slack
has quite an aggressive timeout
for the responses from the web
[INAUDIBLE] for the comments.
And because we are
doing this preloading,
we experience the situation
when actually the function was
executed correctly, but
our Slack didn't wait
for the result. However, like
any further crawl for the API,
it should be extremely,
extremely quick.
So now let me go to the
logs of this function
just to see how much did it take
for the function to execute.
So as you can see,
the first integration
took more than three
seconds just because we're
preloading all the terms.
However, any consecutive request
was processed very quickly
because we could serve
the response directly
from the cache.
So now let's go to
the second function,
which would be written in a way
that it's completely stateless.
So this is the kind of thing
that you can expect when
the writing code functions.
So again, I'm extracting
a text from the request.
Then I'm not using a
local cache as just
before, I'm just directly
calling Knowledge Graph
API each time I'm
calling this function.
I have also this
function.form as a query,
and I do not do any preloading.
So now let's go
back to the channel
and try the second function.
So as you can see, I'm receiving
the results reasonably quickly.
Maybe try one more time.
So in general, we
can see it works.
So let's, again, look
at the exact numbers,
how long this function
was executed each time.
So as you can see, each
time it takes a few hundred
milliseconds to finish.
However, the user experience
is definitely better,
but still the times
are not perfect.
So really, the
best approach would
be the one presented
in the first function.
So we can go to the source.
So again, we are
extracting the query,
but we also used a local cache.
And so, we're trying to retrieve
the result from local cache
if it's there.
If it's not, we are querying
Knowledge Graph API.
However, we don't
use any preloading.
So we optimized
for a cold start,
but we still think
that it makes sense
to use cache on best-for basis.
So let's see how it works.
So for different
terms, it works similar
to the previous function.
However, for the terms that I'm
executing for the second time,
the function executes
much quicker because they
could be served from the cache.
So let me see the logs.
So as you can see,
there's still a cold
that takes longer than
consecutive integration
because this new instance
needed to be created.
However, any consecutive
requests for the same term
can be very quick.
So to summarize, this
demo shows two things.
The first, that you should
truly optimize for a cold
start because they happen.
They happen any time
traffic pattern changes,
and new function instance
needs to be created.
And like as you can
see in this example,
this cold start time,
if it's too long,
may mean that your function
is unavailable for the user.
And the second thing, that
the platform is smart enough
so we will not dispose your
function instance just after it
was executed because it
can anticipate that there
will be some traffic.
So it still makes sense
to use a local cache
to optimize the results.
So this is all that I
prepared, so we can switch back
to the presentation.
JASON POLITES: Thanks, Monika.
Yeah, so what we just saw
there was a much better version
of what I had put on screen
actually done by real engineer.
OK, so just to summarize.
It's important to understand
and optimize for cold starts.
They happen when a new
instance is created.
We will create new instances
when they're needed.
And then, because functions only
serve a single current request
because billing, that
happens even more frequently
in the functions case.
Again, this period of
time in between requests
in the function
case, what do you
do with background threads
or background tasks
that you might be running?
As I said, it's very common
in the sort of web application
world, that you might want to
early respond to a request,
and then do some work,
some more heavy lifting
in the background.
This is not going
to work very well
in a function abstraction
because of this CPU throttling
behavior.
The best practice here is, if
possible, wait for all the work
to complete before you return.
If you want to give the user
or the caller a response early,
then we would recommend that
you use some sort of event bus,
like a Pub/Sub, and queue a
message on that event bus.
Have some other
function somewhere else
that's going to do that
background processing,
and then return.
And it's not just because of
this CPU throttling behavior
that we would say this.
You can imagine the request
comes in, I spawn a thread,
I'm going to do some
heavy lifting over here,
but I'm responding immediately.
And then I get halfway
through the heavy lifting
and the thing crashes
for whatever reason.
Out of memory, process dies.
What happened to that work?
What are the guarantees
that I'm providing myself
over that work?
Probably much better is to have
and at least once guarantee
on an event pass like Pub/Sub
so that if it does fail,
it will retry and
eventually succeed.
Special call out to
connection pools,
somewhat unsolved problem.
Traditional database, MySQL,
Postgres, take your pick,
will have a finite
number of connections
it can deal with on a particular
instance or in aggregate.
You have a spike in traffic.
It overwhelms the database,
too many connections.
And this is displayed
here in my nice graphic.
There's a couple of
things you can do here.
There isn't really a
silver bullet for this
because it's a
fundamental mismatch.
There's a fundamental
sort of impedance mismatch
between a finitely scaled
resource and a, I hesitate
to say infinitely, but much
larger scaled compute layer
above that.
Couple of things you can do,
data access service pattern
and scaling controls.
I think I repeat myself there.
So limit exposure to the
database to only the services
that need it.
Don't just throw your connection
pool into every single function
you do.
Be diligent and judicious about
who is accessing the database.
One other idea is to break
your database up itself.
Now, it's sometimes difficult if
you're relying on foreign keys
and things like that.
But as a pattern,
it can be useful.
Limit connection pools,
the connection pool size.
And we have this somewhat
strange recommendation
that we make in Cloud Functions
where you create a connection
pool to a database like
MySQL, and you limit it
to a size of one.
Why do I need a pool
if it's a pool of one?
Why don't I just
make a connection?
Well, it's limited to one
because, first of all,
you're only dealing with a
single concurrent request.
So the likelihood of you
ever needing more than one
is pretty low.
And secondly, if you
just left it the default,
and let's say the connection
pool framework you're
using says, I'm going to create
10 connections by default,
every single instance
of that function
is going to create 10
database connections.
You're going to run out of
connections pretty quickly.
The reason we say to
use a connection pool
is really just a convenience
because many connection pool
frameworks will do things like
reestablish the connection
if it's found to be bad.
And so, you just get
greater reliability
by leveraging that
kind of retry behavior
that's native to
the connection pool.
Another thing you can do is use
rate limits at an API level,
or scaling limits at the
infrastructure level.
For those who saw the
presentation yesterday,
we talked about a new
feature in Cloud Functions
that's coming soon which allows
you to limit the amount that we
scale up.
So you can have
some levers there
to say, please don't
DDoS my database.
I can only deal with
100 connections.
I know I have one
connection per instance.
I know I have 100
instances maximum.
Or use a, quote unquote,
serverless database
like Cloud Datastore where we
handle that scaling for you.
OK, last point, idempotency.
I have a quote there, which
is sort of often attributed
to Einstein.
I'm not sure if he
actually said it.
Doing the same thing
over and over again
and expecting different results.
Was he talking
about idempotency?
I'm not sure.
So idempotency is when
I perform some operation
and no matter how many times
I perform that operation,
the outcome doesn't change.
It changes the first time, and
then doesn't change thereafter.
So this is really important
because in many circumstances,
particularly in asynchronous
event-based functions,
the guarantees
are at least once.
At least once means will
execute you at least once,
but not exactly once.
And there are
circumstances where you'll
be executed more than once.
And I have a
reference to something
like an UPSERT there where
you can mutate the data.
But if you do it
again, nothing changes.
This is a concrete example.
This is actually my inbox from
about two or three weeks ago.
I don't know if this was
an idempotency thing,
but it seems like
it may have been.
And actually, it
was more than 19.
I took the screenshot
too prematurely.
But you can imagine a situation
where you have a bit of code
and it's sending an email.
But it's sending an email, and
then it's doing something else.
And the something else fails
and they have a retry policy,
and so it's sending email and
then failing, and then sending
an email and failing.
So it is not idempotent.
So a failure that leads to
a retry is correct behavior.
You want this thing to happen.
But a failure that causes
mutations or sends SMS messages
or whatever it might
be and then fails
is definitionally
not idempotent.
So there's many ways
to solve for this.
We're not going to
dig deep on that now.
Just something to be mindful
of, particularly in serverless,
particularly in asynchronous,
where at least once guarantees
are the norm.
[MUSIC PLAYING]